hey I'm at Ferguson and I get to design
c-sharp for a living so that's pretty
cool I'll be doing the first of these
two sessions about c-sharp eight the
other session is actually going to be
Bill Wegener who writes about c-sharp
for a living and so we're both deeply
involved there there's a bunch of new
features in cf8 so that's why we kind of
cheated a little bit here and got
ourselves two of these short sessions
but this first one here is going to be
devoted exclusively to to null so this
got to be twenty five minutes talking
about nothing essentially null is one of
these things that we've learned to live
with but we aren't really super happy
it's been an object-oriented programming
forever null is actually about 53 or 54
years old and the problem with it is
that it poses as an object you can
always get no but you never know where
it's coming from and eventually you
accidentally dereference it and it'll
blow up so it's kind of like this black
hole you circle it but once you're
beyond the event horizon you know you
get the you get the gist here so I'm
gonna switch into visual studio and
we're gonna we're gonna blow some things
up so here's an absolutely innocent
looking little program I create a person
I call a method and I print out the
result of that method that method gets
the length of the person's middle name
and and returns it so it's absolutely
straightforward code nothing to see here
would pass any code review but of course
if we run it then we wait for a while
and then we get a nice little explosion
right because it turns out that middle
name was null but we were to referencing
it and at least now debugger tools can
tell us what it was that was null but
doesn't tell us whether the null came
from why is it there should it have been
there was it my fault was that the api's
fault the person API that I was calling
that's all really muddled and unclear
and so that is what the feature is for
that we call novel reference types in
c-sharp eight
it's one of those features that is about
telling you new things about your
existing programs it's telling you it's
giving you new warnings where your
behavior isn't what we could call null
safe so it's it's attempting to catch
places where you do things that might
are likely to lead to null reference
exceptions since it's adding new
warnings it's a fee that's sort of like
a breaking change if all of a sudden we
start adding morning's to existing code
so don't do that automatically it's a
feature that has to be turned on and the
the most sort of sweeping way of turning
it on I'm going to turn it on here for
the the person library well I'm going to
go into the solution Explorer and turn
it on I just go into the project file
that's this thing I pre added this thing
there's nullable element here and it's
set to disabled and I gonna I'm not
going to enable the feature but it's
disabled by default
so you have to go do this manually now
that I do that let's go look at this
person class it has you know
straightforward auto properties and it
has this constructor I was calling with
a first and a last name and what we see
now is that now it gets a warning after
I turn the feature on and the warning
says that the nun nullable property
middle name is uninitialized so what
does that mean well it means that
essentially it means that it could
apparently now it considers a middle
name to be none nullable in other words
reference types as we know and love them
are now considered to be none nullable
they're not supposed to have null in
them and it catches the fact that since
it's it comes pre initialized to null we
don't change that to something none null
we could of course initialize it kind of
cheekily we could initialize it to null
and then that warning would go away it
goes away but now we'll get another
warning saying hey you can't assign null
in there nice try
and so we're faced with this design
question actually this force is a design
question that we probably should have
asked ourselves earlier but had no way
of expressing in the in the language
should these strings actually be null or
not like is it part of the API to handle
it their null or is it not now
by default the feature is saying they're
not they're not supposed to be null but
what if I want them to be null what with
what if it makes sense for middle names
to be null actually you know it probably
makes sense for all of these to be null
but we're just going to do the middle
name today
you know symmetry exercise for the
reader but I can put a question mark on
string and it's now a nullable reference
type which is the name of the feature as
well I'm signaling that that middle
names can be string or null it can be
they can actually be no I'm signaling
this in my public API and I absolved
myself from having to make sure it's not
null and I get no more warnings in the
API here so now I've come clean with my
API I told the consumers what's what's
null and what isn't and now if I go back
to the program here as a consumer of the
API I now get a warning saying hey this
thing here your dereferencing it even
though it might be a null reference
well why might it be a null reference
well that's because the local variable
is actually now inferred to be of type
string question mark because the middle
name property returns a string question
mark nullable string okay so we're
propagating this potential null Ness
through the system and now I get a
chance so now the API saying hey you're
a problem to deal with nulls but I'm
also getting help from the language
dealing with the nulls I get advance
warning instead of luckily caching it
may be from an exception that gets
thrown before I accidentally shipped to
customers so what can I do well what are
the usual things I would do about a null
I should just do the same things here so
if middle is null this is how I would
usually write it you know return zero
and what you see is that the warning
goes away now actually a little aside
here as of patterns in c-sharp seven I
prefer to say middle is null because
that checks when all even when you've
overridden the equality operator which
wouldn't necessarily work otherwise so
if the middle is null return zero
otherwise return middle to length now
the warning went away
and that's because the compiler
understands that if we get to this point
in the code at this point middle will
not be null and you just checked and if
it wasn't all you went down a different
branch and so that's doing essentially
what we call a flow analysis which is
you know potentially pretty advanced it
will follow the different branches of
your code and we'll track in all these
different places where where nulls may
be and where they may not be it's kind
of similar to definite assignment
analysis which is already in the in the
language but again tracking the state of
a variable as you go through and
actually it's a bit smarter than just
tracking the locals and parameters here
if we go and sort of cut out the
middleman if you will in line the
temporary variable and we we use person
dot middle name directly twice you see
that there's also no warning but remove
the if here just to see you get a
warning on person that middle name
potentially being null but if I check
that property of that parameter then we
track the state of that as well so we
track chains of properties and fields
this is not actually entirely safe if
you think about it the you know somebody
is if another thread is running you know
they could change the middle name
between the test and the and the
reference here or you know I could call
some innocuous-looking method here that
actually goes and changes the middle
name behind the scenes or whatnot and
the compiler can't see it so this is
this is a bit dangerous but the way we
think about the nullable feature is it
gives you warnings warnings are places
where we warn you if we're pretty
certain that you have a problem and
there's a lot of existing code out there
that looks like this that works just
like this and if we were to flag all of
that with this feature it would be
useless to be impossible for you to
upgrade your existing code to use the
nullable features so we give you a pass
and this probably safe thing and there
are a couple of other places where you
know the feature isn't ironclad it will
let through things that could
potentially be wrong and not give you
warnings there it's not a guarantee
against null reference exceptions it's
just going to find you most of them so
that's good to know but if you want to
avoid that kind of situation you can
write code that's sort of correct by
construction you can try to do that we
had that local variable before that's a
good way of doing that you can also use
things like the question dot operator
that oh not there but here that checks
for null and only does the dereference
if the thing wasn't know now of course
we get an int question mark but then we
can use the null coalescing operator to
take any nulls that come out of that and
turn them into zero so that's correct by
construction in the sense that you only
read the variable once and you don't
depend on its state remaining the same
from check two to consumption if we go
back to this version here another
another couple of ways that you can be
correct by construction if we just go
and well actually let's look at what
happens if you also had a nullable
person coming in now we have to
potentially nullable things we could use
the person question mark dot here in the
in the condition and that actually
checks that the person is not null and
the middle name is not null and sure
enough you you don't get any warnings
down here the compiler tracks that
they're both not null whereas if that
check hadn't been there both would have
been a problem that's actually two sets
of square goes on top here so let's go
and invert up wrong button
let's go and invert the the condition
here I've got an invert if and talked
about what if I want to check that
something isn't null rather than is null
so the new pattern matching the new
features that are added to pattern
matching actually help a bit here I
don't have to write it like this with
you know and not and the parentheses
here instead there's a new pattern in
town that I can use to check that
something is not null it looks like this
so it sort of means is object think
about is an object is a thing is
something so think about this as as
meaning something
that that means that if that thing is
something then you know go down the true
branch so what's nice about that is we
can actually name the something so
there's optionally you can give it a
name and this pattern here this
something pattern we don't actually call
it that but I'll get back to that in a
second we give it we give the something
a name that can be used in the true
branch where it isn't null and then we
could say middle dot length here and
again we get no warnings because we are
in the true branch we could also go a
step further what this actually is is a
degenerate form of a new pattern
recursive pattern called a property
pattern so a property pattern is one
where you can drill we check for null
but then we you could drill down into
properties of the object that we're
currently matching on and then we can
apply further patterns at the next level
down so this string here has a length
and I could just use a bar pattern to
grab that length into a local variable
and I could actually just return that
local variable so just return the length
and now I don't need the middle anymore
so I'm I'm using pattern matching here
now to dig in and get the in case
everything is not null I get the right
thing out and returning of course now I
could easily turn this into a
conditional expression and you know it
starts getting nice and you can make it
an expression body method as well so you
know you can play with this but the
upshot is you can use these new fangled
pattern based methods of null checking
if you want to and these features
interoperate very well the pattern
matching the question dot operator and
and inaudible reference types but if you
just use the old-fashioned if that's
perfectly fine too and we will check
your code as best we can so that's sort
of the ops your that's that's a core of
the of the nullable reference types
language feature you can you get
warnings when you put null into nan
nullable reference types you can then
annotate things to become know
reference types and then you get
warnings when you do you reference those
without a check as in our code here now
there are a couple of refinements that
we've added to the feature we found as
we were annotating the core libraries
for instance that there are places where
you kind of want to know better than the
compiler or help the compiler a little
bit there's actually a feature that we
used to call the dammit operator but
we're not allowed to its the bang the
postfix exclamation mark here which
means I know better than what you think
about this expression here so you might
think that middle is null but I as a
programmer know better so just shut up
with your warnings I think we call it
the null ignoring operator or something
instead it's not it's not exclamation
mark dot there those aren't a single
operator the exclamation mark is its own
operator and so you can just say I know
better that would be really bad to do
here because and usually it's bad to do
because usually you don't know better
you just think you do so let's not use
that one but then there are ways in
which certain helper methods for
instance they have special behavior
around nulls that it will be really nice
to communicate so before when I said
when I said if something wasn't null
here or something was no I relied on the
fact that the compiler could see that
there was a null check but what if that
null check is inside of a helper method
for instance what if we use string dot
is null or empty to check whether this
string is whether the string should just
return 0 as its length let's do that for
a second what we see is well you see
that
[Music]
if stringer is now our empty
oh I should pass it now or an argument
of course if the middle name is is not
null or empty between zero and what you
see now is that the warning goes away so
somehow the compiler knows that this
method that when that method returns
false then the thing is not null and the
way it knows it is that it's annotated
with a special attribute so we have a
handful of attributes that signal
special null behavior that you can put
on members and and parameters and so on
in this case it's an attribute on the on
the string question mark typed value
parameter here that says that this thing
is not null when the result of the
method is false and there's a little set
of like ten of them you can read in the
docs what they are you can use to refine
your API if they have special null
behavior and we do that a lot around the
core libraries where a lot of utility
methods are I think it's probably going
to be less common in in most other code
actually but here and there it's really
useful to to tweak the null ability
behavior that the compiler sees in the
public API so those are a couple of ways
of tweaking now I mentioned a couple
times you know existing code and when
you have a feature that when you turn it
on for existing code it lights up with
all these warnings for potentially large
a large project for instance it's not
really feasible it's to convert it all
over in one go I think most people would
find it a little daunting you get like
10,000 warnings and on a large project
and go and fix them all and so you want
to do it piecemeal and the way you can
do a piecemeal is that you can actually
turn the the nullable feature on and off
at a file level as well so I can say
nullable I say as a new directive in
c-sharp I can I can say nullable
disabled and now for the rest of this
file
the nullable feature is disabled now you
can see I also get a warning on the on
the question mark here because when I
disable a feature I don't get to use
nullable reference types in my
code I could say let's say that I wanted
to I wanted to annotate my library and
give my consumers good nullable
annotations but I don't have the time to
fix all the warnings that show up in my
in my internal implementations of it I
could disable just the warnings and
that's actually that's introducer that's
fine
I can disable the warnings and now the
annotations are still allowed but
warnings are turned off I can also
conversely I could disable just
annotations and now I still get the
warnings but the public API is not
affected and of course I can do this not
just at the top of the file I can do it
anywhere in the file so so now the
warnings or the annotations rather are
enabled until I get down here and now
after that I'm no longer allowed to say
put a question mark down I start getting
a warning for that so this is a way that
you can you can take chunks of like file
by file or even chunk by chunk of your
files and get the nullable warnings and
annotations handled for those bit by bit
you don't have to look at all the
warnings at once speaking of adoption I
think that another feature a feature
that actually or a property of this
feature that is a little remembrance
romanís and when we did a sync is that
in order to make use of the feature to
make good use of the feature ass like an
end user an app writer or something like
that you really rely on the libraries
that that you have a dependency on to
adopt this feature also because if you
interact with a library that didn't have
the knowable feature on and you won't
get any warnings from interacting with
that library and only later when they do
get around to adding these annotations
you start getting warnings maybe for any
null unsafe use you have of that library
and so there's a bit of sort of an
ecosystem adoption thing where this
language feature it's useful in and of
itself but it certainly gets more and
more useful the more of the world starts
adopting it
and so in order to talk about that let's
go back to slides quickly here so
essentially what we want to suggest and
this is of course is up to you out there
but we kind of want to suggest that if
you're a library author and that
includes Microsoft by the way in in a
you know it's a big time library author
if your library author may be considered
the time between now and dotnet 5 which
is slated for November of next year
treat that as the nullable adoption
phase this is the time where it would be
a really good idea for you to adopt a
null in your public API and the surface
area that your clients consume and then
on the flip side if you're a client of
these api's expect there to be that to
be some churn in that period of time
right so expect that you won't get
nullable annotations from your favorite
libraries tomorrow it might be whenever
it's natural for them next to ship
version and you know when they have had
time to go through and do the work and
roll out normally so let's give us give
everyone a breather and think about the
next year in a bit ask the nullable
adoption phase where there will be some
churn and if you adopt this as a client
you should be okay with your library
sort of gradually coming online and
therefore warnings gradually maybe
popping up in your code and that might
still be the best way for you to go I
would that's certainly how I will go but
if you don't want that churn maybe wait
until done at five before you turn the
nullable feature on as a client and then
every hopefully most of the ecosystem
has settled and you get and you know the
finished nullable annotations for most
of the libraries and this goes for
Microsoft as well we haven't adopted
these for all our libraries because we
also kind of want to learn from the
adoption phase and expand you know a
knowledge adjust here and there and it's
also a lot of work just to go and update
the entire dotnet BCL and so we've
updated the core libraries with nullable
annotations but we actually consider
them in preview a little bit that we
try to keep them stable but we will
change if we did something wrong if we
had like if you thought about something
wrong or just messed up we want to
reserve the right to fix those up until
done at five so that's just a way that
we can kind of soften the blow of
something that introduces new warnings
and existing code and not making it you
know a big sort of green squiggle jungle
for everyone out there
I also for library riders a lot of
library writers don't just target dotnet
core three all right you want you want
reach and you want to target dontist
Anna - oh maybe so you can get on a
framework and and that that broad set of
things you can target that way and so
we're cognizant of that and we what we
recommend to do say if you're using
visual studio is you know multi target
between guttacore 300 and darkness Dana
- oh and that means you can't turn on C
Charvet in the in the UI of Visual
Studio for instance because lots of
c-sharp eight things won't work properly
when you do that but if you consider
yourself an expert you can go and
manually do it in the project file and
that's probably the best way to go as
you try to both and this should work
just fine that you try to both get the
nullable annotations that are in dotnet
core 300 and get the warnings for those
but you and but you also want to
generate code that that reaches all of
that Nets Dana - oh so this is how we
would come in if you go and if you want
to check out more things there are blog
post out there that have come out over
the last couple years around it and the
docs are already excellent around noble
reference types so here's a set of of
links that you can follow and and get
the docs alrighty thank you very much
Kendra thank you Mads so Matt's talk
primarily about nullable reference types
which we devoted an entire half-hour to
because that's the one that is going to
change how you code the most it's going
to affect those warnings that you talked
about it's gonna affect the libraries
that you use in terms of how we work
with the code that you have I need to
talk about all the fun stuff it's just
things that you can adopt that
we'll just make your life better but
they're not gonna introduce warnings as
soon as you turn them on so there's a
couple different themes that are really
true about what was the Antonine c-sharp
ate outside of nullable reference types
we're going to talk about it as being
more modern and more productive we're
going to increase your productivity and
we're going to add features that make it
easier for you to work with modern
development scenarios primarily those
are cloud-based device based programs
that run across multiple machines so
let's look quickly at that catalog of
features and then we going to dive right
into code so the ones that are going to
support these modern cloud scenarios
we're going to be talking about async
enumerables we're going to talk about
more patterns in more places and how you
can use pattern matching which will do a
lot more different things as we're
combining applications and combining
code from other places we're going to
talk about default interface members
ways to add versions on to an interface
ways to provide implementation in an
interface and to be able to update those
as part of a distributed program I want
to talk about indices and ranges which
is just a nicer cleaner syntax for
working with large sequences of data
whether that be arrays large data sets
that come from an ml dotnet program and
so on we're also going to breeze through
quickly a lot of different smaller
features that are really nice ways to
increase your productivity using
statement static local functions
read-only members null coalescing
assignment unmanaged constraints and
interpolated verbatim strings these are
different features that you can just add
into your daily habits and start writing
a little bit more productive a little
bit more concise code and make the
experience a little bit better
so now from that that's everything that
we're going to be talking about and
that's more than enough talking now
let's look at the code and let's
actually look at those features in
action so what I have here is I'm using
Visual Studio for Mac as part of that
dotnet core story of cross-platform open
source and free let's make this just a
little bit bigger so my main program
here we're using one of the features
that was in one of the previous versions
so we're going to have async iterators
so my main method is also asynchronous
let's look at the idea behind what an
async iterator does if you think about
everything we had to write in order to
do a synchronous grab data and then work
with that data and then consume it you
would do an asynchronous call and you
would have to wait until all the data
was available and then you get that
entire large data set and then you would
work with that data set using async
enumerators when you write the code that
retrieves the data asynchronously now
you can put that into an async
enumerator method such as this one here
where as the data is available
you immediately yield return it when the
data is not available and you need to
say get the next page and a graph QL
query or make another web service call
to get more data
well now it's going to a wait and do
something asynchronous and then the next
block of data comes back so let's run
this application
and I want you to watch how the screen
Scrolls as we do this and that went just
a little bit too quick
so let's run that one a little bit we'll
add a little bit more of a delay here
you
and
let's make sure we have the change to
make sure I'm running the right
application no that should be right
let's build
and then we'll run this one
so what we're going to see is that as
the first data packet is available will
immediately see
those first ten elements and then we'll
see a pause while I'm simulating doing a
web request to go get some more data
and then we'll see the next hunk go by
so we'll see we'll get some data after
the first pause for five seconds get the
first block and now it's pausing to do
that web Woodcrest to get some more data
it's going to come back and there's the
next block and you notice that even as
we're consuming that iterator it's going
to just a wait for each and the calling
code doesn't need to know exactly
anything about the page size or how that
data is going to get returned or when it
will pause it can simply continue to ask
for the next data data element if the
data elements already there it's going
to immediately return if the data
element is not there and it needs to
instead go get the next datablock then
we'll go ahead and it will be
asynchronous it will await and then when
the next data block is right it can
resume processing
so that's a sink iterators and we find
that that's an incredibly useful feature
when we're talking about doing anything
with working with distributed programs
where you get some data have to go get
the process some of it get some more
data and have to go process some of it
again so now I'm going to go ahead and
just remove tasks and async here because
otherwise I'm going to continue to get
warnings because the rest of the code in
this demo is not asynchronous and let's
look at our patterns matching demo and
this is one that we've covered in Docs
but the scenario behind this is imagine
that you know you're building an
application that is composed of a number
of different applications that are
delivering data to you so in this
instance it's an application that
calculates tolls for a busy highway
going into and out of a city well as
luck would have it and there's a lot of
real-life scenarios that we have to work
with are constructed the companies that
put together the software that registers
cars or registers delivery trucks or
registers taxis and buses they built
totally separate software systems that
you now have to integrate so what that
means is even though in a classic model
where we look at object orientation and
we'd say we can just do that an object
oriented thing and have you know car and
and trucks and taxis and buses derived
from a vehicle class and have a virtual
method to calculate the toll and provide
different implementations we really
don't have that here because we were
constrained to use these data types that
we've been given from someone else and
that's where pattern matching comes in
so if we look at how we're calculating
the tolls if we were to take a vehicle
and we switch on what type it is well we
can set a cost for a car set a cost for
the taxi set a cost for the delivery
truck and we're
the shape of the data and the kind it is
and we're not relying on a virtual
hierarchy that we've imposed upon those
types but we're just putting them
together in terms of knowing some things
about it what we can expand on that more
and then as more business rules come in
we may have some advanced rules that say
well once we put more people in the car
you know cars should get a little
cheaper so if I'm going to say my car
and if a car's got passengers with if
it's got two or more so it's got two and
I'm going to say then it's only 1.5 and
now if you look I'm not going to get a
little bit of squiggles coming in here
because I shouldn't be I'm not covering
every case with the car so I would have
to add another car
with a default of 2.0 okay and now if I
were to say well if there's no
passengers in there we can put these in
and if it's zero well now you're gonna
owe a little bit more you have to pay I
guess I didn't have that one but if it's
got three or more passengers then you
only have to pay a dollar and so on so
for each different case what we can now
do is we leap into instead of just
looking at the type once we know the
type
we're going to look at some of the
properties of that type in a recursive
pattern so if it's a car and one of the
properties has a certain value then we
can go through and and learn a little
bit more and then we can also learn
about if it's some other type completely
we can catch those where somebody is
probably a programmer error someone
passed in the wrong type or if someone
passes a null that would be a different
case that we could work with and then we
could do something where we could get
even more advanced and we could say you
know if depending on the days of the
week and depending on the time of the
day well then we have some other
business rules if it's a weekday well
then we're going to spend a little bit
more and depending on the time band
we're going to add a little bit more
other code to say morning rush coming
into the city should cost more evening
rush out of the city should cost more
now if we look here at this one for his
weekday you can see that this is pretty
repetitive right now well I can change
that by it I'm going to delete all these
because they're all the same and then
Saturday and Sunday I should return
false but if it's not Saturday or Sunday
from this enum I should be able to just
return true so now I can go well it's a
I can look at the exceptions because
there's only two of them and then I can
treat those that are not exceptions
that's just a general rule to say that
must be a weekday and we can do some of
the same things here in terms of the
time band where we can look at depending
on the time we have a few if else's here
we could refactor that if we wanted to
as well and then if you look at our peak
time premium now here what we're doing
is we're also using that new switch
statement what we're going to construct
a tuple of the three variables we care
about we care about whether or not it's
a weekday we care about if it's
overnight if it's daytime or if it's
morning rush hour or evening rush hour
and we may care about whether or not
it's inbound or outbound and now if I
were to build an entire table of all
those I would get you know a weekday is
either true or false times the time band
of which there are four so that would be
eight rows and then whether or not it's
inbound is another boolean of two
different ways so I would get sixteen
different rows here and then we can
start to simplify this and by
simplifying it I can come into these
these rules where if it's over night or
day time really doesn't matter if it's
inbound or not so I'll just leave that
as an underscore so any value would be
fine and I have those rules and if it's
morning or evening rush and it's a
weekday that's covered under the next
two two rules here where I'm going to
check all three variables and on those
instances because peak time inbound is
more expensive and peak time outbound in
the evening is more expensive well then
we're gonna add a bit more of a premium
and the other cases there's no
particular premium and there's no
discount so we'll just leave all the
others underscores and discards and that
will fall through as a default case so
this is one of the questions we get on
this in tax is why did we pick
underscore rather than using the default
which is what's been on a switch state
for a long time and a big reason is
there are a lot of cases here where we
would start to use multiple variables or
multiple properties and what we'll end
up with is by simplifying it
we'll get those discs up discards or
default we don't care what the value is
in more than one place and it just
looked kind of weird if this last one
was going to be default default default
that seems kind of odd and doesn't
really seem to fit the syntax so this
switch expression is now doing some
different things in the switch statement
that we've all familiar with it in its
construction the two big changes that
are in the syntax when you start to
adapt this is that what you'll see is we
start by giving the variable that we're
going to switch on followed by the
switch keyword and then we're going to
have the cases in terms of what are the
types the property's property constants
that we're going to be switching on and
the reason we did it that way is this
composes very well in more complicated
scenarios I can go from here and then I
can take the output of this one and then
I can also multiply it by this peak time
premium or if you look here I'm
composing inside of by calling that is
weekday or get time band which are also
switch based and then composing directly
into that so if we run this I have some
test code up here that's going to you
just create a bunch of different solo
writers rideshare or full fans and empty
vans and so on and so forth and try to
walk through all of those cases
including some that are invalid where we
don't pass a vehicle type in at all or
pass a null in and and see what happens
so we can go ahead just build and run
this one which will says it's not
asynchronous it doesn't have those
pauses in it we'll start a little bit
smaller it will make our font noticeably
bigger on this one
yeah finding that one right as quick as
I would like sorry about that
unless we so
this one and
the next one that we want to discuss is
the other big one that kind of changes
it really helps with these programs that
work across multiple machines we're
going to talk about adding default
interface members which is one of these
that has caused a fair amount of a
little bit of concern especially the
people who have been familiar with C C++
and multiple inheritance so there are a
lot of rules in terms of how you can use
default interface implementations which
will really try to do a lot to make sure
that you really can't get into that
default diamond of death scenario that
was possible in C++ with multiple
inheritance so if we look at what we're
trying to do here with a default
interface member we can look at the idea
of a logger so we're going to write some
kind of a strength to some form of a
lock that log may take different
different implementations in this
contrived example I've got a console
logger that writes to the console I have
a database logger that also writes to
the console because didn't want to add a
database and everything for this this
demo so it's going to write to the
console but it's going to say that it
wrote something to a database and if you
note that what we did here is we added
an implementation to this so now this
logger method can now be called on any
type that implements this console log or
a database logger interface so we can
implement the derived interface and that
will just inherit and accept that
implementation so now if we look I have
added a logger factory that we can take
the constant of an enum of which kind of
logger you want to create and I'm just
going to return one of those if one
doesn't exist well then we're going to
throw an exception and note that that's
using that same pattern matching again
so we can use that in other scenarios
such as this where we're doing some form
of a dependency injection and now if we
look I can just create a logger and if I
want to log that it's going to log the
hello world or it's going to log it into
my
database type based on which one was
created either those factors will work
and it will come into play and it will
do the correct thing in terms of writing
to that particular log so rebuild and
we'll go ahead and run and we'll see the
two different messages to come out hello
or hello insert it into the database and
where I want to talk a little bit about
that deadly Diamond of death and
multiple inheritance is if we look here
and if I took my database logger
I can change this and I'm going to just
implement
doot-doot-doot from this class I'm going
to now make this implement
you
change this to an interface
with that that implementation
we just need to create a class
let's change the name here to make this
an eye database logger and that's going
to implement a database logger and I
don't need to provide any implementation
I could have whatever else I wanted in
there and now if I wanted to try to get
into this weird state where I said you
know I want to do both so now let's add
this to the council logger as well we'll
make this an interface
and now
just make this compile
to make a class it's a council logger
which entered implements I counsel
logger it doesn't have any
implementation and that that works and
if I wanted to take the database logger
and I wanted to also implement the icon
so logger now we're going to see we
instead of that deadly diamond of death
that would throw some exceptions or do
some strange behavior at runtime you can
see I'm getting red squiggles I can't do
this what the compiler is going to tell
me is that both of these have an
implementation for that ilogger dot log
method and none of them is better than
the other none of them is closer in the
hierarchy so I can't it won't compile so
what you're going to find and we've got
some docs that go through and walk
through creating default interface
implementations and adding new features
to these what you'll find is that any of
the scenarios where the compiler can't
absolutely figure out which one should
be running which one should be correct
you're going to get a compiler error and
you're going to have to explicitly say
which one you wanted or provide a class
implementation and come back from that
class into creating in that class which
one of the interface implementations you
want it's a call and be explicit about
it and then once it compiles what the
compiler will guarantee is there is
exactly one better method that is the
correct one to call and the other thing
to note is that notice that any of these
implementations now have to use default
excuse me explicit interface
implementations so if you rev an
interface and add a method that some
class is already used what you'll end up
with in your default interface
implementation is that new method you
added to the interface will only be
called if the object is called through
the interface reference just like an
explicit interface implementation
otherwise the method that was already in
added in the class that one will win
with overload resolution
so a lot of work went into this and
where that went is mostly to try to make
sure that whatever methods you pick are
going to end up being the correct method
for your scenario
has a lot to do with working on these
distributed programs is indices and
ranges I'm gonna just show a lot of the
code and I doubt I'll run this one
because it once you see the code the
code pretty much shows what goes on so
what we did with default at earth
indices and ranges is it's a better way
and a much more concise way to use
bracket notation to look at a single
element either from the start or from
the end of an array or to look at a
range anywhere inside an array or a span
or some sequence of elements so if you
look at here I've got an array where
we've got the quick brown fox jumped
over the lazy dog and you can see the
index from the start starts at zero and
goes up through eight one of the
controversial things on this feature is
if you look at the index on the end it's
going to start from hat one and then
move up to hat nine now the reason for
that is hat zero is the length of the
array so it is actually one past the end
and it points to the very end of the
array so that's where you can think of
hat zero is sequence that length hat one
is sequence that length minus one which
matches up with the last element now
where this feature works fairly well we
can write out things either from either
end we can also take a slice of it if
you look in the second demo it would
take the last two words from bang to or
from hat two up to hat zero and if you
notice here ranges are exclusive so the
last element in a range is not included
in that range and where that gets
important is as we look at some of the
other ones here where we really look at
a lot of the rules which is why we chose
an exclusive range is if you look
numbers from X through y is the same as
the range of Y minus X it has that many
elements and these other rules once
again go x2 why why does e they should
be sequential and non overlapping x2 hat
X should remove exactly the same number
of elements from both sides of the
the sequence so 0 2 hat 0 is the entire
sequence 1 2 hat 1 is peeling one
element off each end and one of the real
scenarios where we use this a lot is if
you're working through large data sets
you might take a moving average over any
number of elements so we start with how
many do we have and we take the next 10
and we just keep moving through and we
start to see how the sequence moves but
kind of balance it a little bit
and then from there now we're getting
into just these things work they're
really just small little features but
they just make your life more productive
so let's start with our using statement
so if we look at the using statement
I've just got these nested usings and
I'm just going to start removing some
extra characters go some brackets
and we can do the same on the next line
you
when we reformat this it starts to look
a little bit cleaner
this morning and then everything would
line up and we just have these different
usings all in one area and because it's
now using statement I need the
semicolons and they're instead of just
all that fireman's ladder of brackets
using multiple items we get just one how
much more do we got thank you you can
keep going if you want to there's a full
time there's a few more
would be static local functions we sell
local functions in a in c-sharp seven
and what we've added with static local
functions is now we can look at
something and say I know this local
function does not use any of the
arguments that are in its outer scope
and the compiler and the JIT can make
some optimizations on those so if I want
to take something like this and say I
really wanted this to be something so
that I know it never uses any of the
outer scope variables I should be able
to declare it a static if you don't that
when I do this now I'm seeing red
squigglies under start and end so now I
have to update that to say I'm going to
want to pass those in
and make new copies of those variables
so that I'm not capturing something from
the outside so what the compiler will do
here is it helps make your code motor
more efficient if you don't think you're
supposed to be using some of the outer
variables and capturing those and making
a closure which can be a little
expensive especially in hot paths
something like this will let you then
say I know I don't want to do that I'll
turn on that static feature and then
what I'm going to do is make sure that I
can't write code that would violate that
and we walk on to read only members
right now we've in in the C sharp seven
time frame we added read only Struck's
so I could create a struct and and
guarantee that it would never change so
what we want to do now is to be able to
give you a little bit more better ways
to do that and if I look at to string I
should be able to say that should be
read only because two strings should
never change anything
well it's annoyed because it's a static
is going to do that so I'm going to have
to change distance so now I'll say that
that's also read-only and now what that
does is it tells the compiler this
method is not supposed to change the
state of the struct
because of that then if it was passed by
ref to compile ur could then go well
this isn't supposed to and it won't
change the state of that struct so then
we can move forward from that and it can
make some optimizations so if you know
something isn't supposed to change state
you can add that modifier and the
compiler will enforce your your intent
we're going to do just one more because
the last two are really quite small and
we will look at the null coalescing
assignment and this is one of these that
really will help as you start to adapt
nullable reference types which Matt's
talked about in part one where a lot of
what we have is we want to be able to
assign something and ensure that it's
not null so by using this null
coalescing assignment what I'm saying is
presence here I'm going to say that this
numbers collection is either going to be
the value had already had or if its
value was null go create a new one and
then I'm going to add some elements to
it and I would try to add I if I is null
well then it will actually add 17 if I
is not in all it would add whatever the
value is so that's a way to instead of
having to start sprinkling your code
with all this if something isn't null
just make a default assignment and put
the right thing in place and with that
we'll go back to into finishing up and
talk with a lot of the questions these
were the features that we had the ones I
didn't talk about was the unmanaged
constraint
primarily it's going to be used by
libraries for very high performance
scenarios and interpolated verbatim
strings which means now the dollar sign
and the @ sign can be in either order
and with that let's go to camera and get
some questions great thanks so much